[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look then at
what is on the front pages time then to
see what's making the headlines with
Sonia soda the chief lead writer at The
Observer and Mark Wallace the chief
executive of the total politics group
welcome and good evening to both of you
so let's take a look at the front pages
shall we starting with the arrest and
later release of the treasurer of the
Scottish national party uh it's the lead
for the Scotsman with the headline SMP
crisis deepens after second arrest
the NHS has broken the telegraph uh
quotes the labor leader kirstama who
says a fifth of a e patients are going
to hospital because they can't get to
see their GP
the case of Damien Bendel who was
released from jail after probation
officer said he was low risk but who
then killed his pregnant partner and
three children is the lead story for the
Metro
the mirror leads with what it calls the
five Tory broken promises on outlawing
zombie knives and machetes I mean
children are still dying
the attack by Eco protesters on the
world snooker championships leads the
sun with demands that the venture
capitalist son who leaded faces what the
paper calls tough Justice
while the male asks when somebody will
get a grip on what it calls the Eco
Fanatics or when will someone get a
great brother
the financial times leads with an 18
slump in profits as U.S Bank Goldman
Sachs at U.S Bank Goldman Sachs after an
unsuccessful move into consumer Banking
and the Daily Star reports that the boss
of Google is worried about the possible
dangers of artificial intelligence even
though he admits he doesn't fully
understand it
he's not alone a reminder by scanning
the QR code you'll see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us so let's head to Our Guest
there Sonia do you mind picking up I
don't know if you heard what Mark had to
say but anyway take it away
I did hear um some of what Mark was
saying and I think there's been um it's
a massive issue for the SMP it's humzie
Joseph his first few weeks in the job
and this is the second arrest of the
very senior SMP official today we found
out that he the treasure has also been
released without charge in the same way
that the treasurer Peter Murrell who is
uh who was married to Nicholas sturgeon
former first minister of Scotland he was
also arrested and released without
charge
um but they're a very serious questions
overhanging the SMP around its finances
around what happened to the resources
that were raised for an independence
campaign how they were spent were they
spent on that campaign were they spent
on something else very serious questions
as well around
um a motorhome that was apparently
bought as a battle bus for use during
lockdowns except there weren't any
lockdowns after it was bought and it was
apparent currently left art in front of
Peter Morrell's mother's house so it all
looks quite
um serious to the SMP
um it's obviously a very complicated
investigation it's an investigation
about any potential Financial
misconduct in the party so it would
probably take a number of weeks to play
out but the SMP are also without
Auditors which is very serious for a
political party so we know it's Auditors
resigned towards the end of last year
it's not been able to appoint new
Auditors and it needs to be filing
accounts with the Electoral commission
uh in July so all in all it's really not
a good situation for the SMP in the
first few weeks of humza users tenure as
first minister of Scotland and certainly
uh two of the others who had stood to be
leader Kate Forbes and Ash Regan
speaking out today and certainly Kate
Forbes that the allegations about the
party's finances were mind-blowing and
the telegraph reporting I don't know if
we can get a mark maybe we'll try again
um that yeah the s p is turning on Hamza
Yousaf because he won't suspend Nicholas
sturgeon as an MSP is that a necessary
step Mark do you think
hmm
it's a taking part of this Challenge and
you know for one person hasn't had a
huge amount of problems about this it is
of course the first Minister herself
you'll remember when she did uh decided
to step down it wasn't it wasn't a
hugely interesting account if she
decided at that moment
but I think we were going to get more
from Earth about exactly what led to
that which you and didn't know the
situation
or not Mark I think we need to reboot
you not you obviously but your sound
so I'm going to move on if you don't
mind and uh head to Sonia with the daily
mail
um we've clearly seen a number of uh
protests against sporting events Sonia
uh when will someone get a grip of the
Eco Fanatics that's the front page of
the Daily Mail as protesters prepare to
descend on London this weekend the
weekend of the London Marathon
well this seems to be a bit of a
perennial story when you've got a period
where Eco protesters are sort of
protesting uh the climate crisis uh and
climate change the government always
weighs in and says well clearly the law
isn't strong enough we need to do
something I'm not so sure about that we
know these protests can be extremely
disruptive but there's lots of laws that
are already designed to uh uh to deal
with very disruptive protests so for
example you've got public order offenses
for example so this always to me has a
bit of a ring of the government trying
to look like it's doing something at a
time when it knows there's going to be
lots of unpopular uh disruption
um when you take a step back I'm really
not sure what these protests are
achieving because we already know when
you look at the polling evidence the
public are concerned about the climate
crisis and I'm not sure that actually by
disrupting very popular big events like
the Grand National like big nuclear
events like potentially
um the the marathon I'm not sure what
exactly the protesters objectives are
really because I'm not sure that that's
what's going to win rounds greater
public support and public pressure for
the government to act
yes and Richie sunac uh the mail telling
us uh vowing to bring in tougher laws to
stop protesters ruining Great British
sporting events where they're selfish
and Reckless Behavior they talked about
this before haven't they um Sonia uh
we'll wait and see if it happens
yeah that's right I mean I'm I'm pretty
skeptical as you probably heard in my
voice just Sarah Anna because I think
there are these laws already exist to
deal with disruptive protests and in
fact you know in the last couple of
years the government has passed even
stricter laws um around protests giving
the police more Powers this to me always
has the feel of the government sort of
saying it's going to do something when
actually I'm not sure that new laws are
needed it's more about effective
policing
but just the times is just in Sonia I'm
going to stay with you apologies to Mark
we are trying to fix um his sound or he
is I don't know it might be an internet
connection his end
I don't know but uh anyway the times is
just in and it's decided to go with the
Fox News defamation Dominion voting
systems settlement uh in Delaware the
breaking news from earlier
787.5 million dollars it's cost them it
was a 1.6 billion uh dollar lawsuit
um but clearly this is very significant
and uh in some respects as disappointed
social media who wanted to unpick this
properly
yeah absolutely and it's a really big
settlement as you just um said that um
Anna and there were a lot of people
who've been waiting a long time for this
case because I think if it hit the
courtroom they were going to be
absolutely explosive allegations
um made against Fox News in terms of
what its news Executives did and did not
know to be the truth about the election
obviously Fox news coverage played a big
role in um The Fallout after president
Trump lost the election
um and in the Insurrection on Capitol
Hill on January the 6th
um Fox News sort of supported uh
president Trump's claims that the the
election was fixed and this is uh one of
the companies that owns some of the
voting machines Dominion suing for
defamation
um in the U.S courts now you know we
were really getting close to the wire
this was about to be heard in a
courtroom
um a jury has even been you picked but
then this very big settlement was
reached at the last minute it may not be
the end of the story though because
there are other outstanding lawsuits in
fact there's another company that owns
voting machines that has got a case um
currently working its way through the
legal system against Fox so we're gonna
have to wait and see whether um Fox
decides to settle that in the same way
or whether it goes through um what would
be a lengthy Court battle which I think
would involve some um quite explosive uh
Revelations it's likely to um in a U.S
courtroom yes so Fox News facing another
court hearing in New York but also
Dominion suing other media companies as
well and let's head to prepayment meters
shall we obviously there's been a lot of
reporting on this in various newspapers
including the times
um Crackdown on prepayment meters the
code bans the forcible installation for
over 85s the Charities of course calling
the voluntary rules to too soft where do
you stand
well I agree with them so um it's a new
voluntary code that's being suggested by
ofcom the energy regulator it comes
after those really terrible Revelations
about energy companies using some sort
of debt collection companies
um sort of Bayless essentially forcing
their way into people's properties uh
installing prepay meters in some very
vulnerable households so are
very young children
households with disabled people who
really cannot be without heat and then
also older households now what oftcom
are proposing here it's a voluntary code
festival and Charities have got an issue
with that consumer Charities because
we've had lots of voluntary code and you
know it turns out that energy companies
were sort of flaunting them in order to
put in these prepayment meters and it's
a voluntary code that only applies to
the 85s and over and it sounds like the
determinedly ill and Charities are
asking the question who's going to
regular regulate this voluntary code how
do you prove that you're terminally ill
what about people living with for
example long-term disability what about
households and very young children so I
think charity is a right to be concerned
that if it's just a voluntary code and
if there are some quite it's quite
tightly prescribed there's a real risk
that again energy companies just kind of
interpret the rules very flexibly and
you have bailiffs forcing their way into
vulnerable houses to install these
prepayment meters for people who just
simply cannot afford to be cut off from
energy for health reasons or because for
example they've got tiny babies in their
households and go to the financial times
uh Rishi sunak aware perhaps of what
labor is doing with a business reset
plan what are you hearing
well this is really interesting there
are two two big things happening in this
story first is that the Prime Minister
has been beefing up his team in terms of
their experience and expertise in
Downing Street for the people doing
liaison and Outreach to business and
second he's launched what's effectively
a charm offensive really trying to get
on the front first and trying to press
the Flesh and win over business before
this of course is meant to be his strong
point it was meant to be as a former
Chancellor one of the areas where he
will be ahead to start off with what
this is really is in reaction to several
months now of growing conservative
concern about the way in which team
starmer have upped their game on this
front even back at the party and party
conference season I remember speaking to
lobbyist after lobbyists company after
company who was saying they were very
impressed for the first time really
vaccine since since Ed Balls used to do
this in almost a decade ago now
um and how neighborhood turned things
around and they were meeting they're
getting loads of Shadow cabinet FaceTime
which flattered them and every time they
met people they they were saying we're
here to listen to what you want which
also contrasted quite sharply with what
they were sometimes getting from
government ministers so this is the
conservatives trying to get you know to
compete with obviously what they see as
a growing challenge yes and uh the Ft
suggesting that Labor's expecting to
sell out its business events at this
Autumn's annual conference in Liverpool
um concerted on health too possibly if
we take a look at the Daily Telegraph
the NHS is broken
um
saying that the problem is of course
that people can't get to a gp's
appointment so they're sent to a e in a
fifth are now going to hospital which
obviously blocks up emergency care
yes that's right so this is a big
intervention from Kirsten on the NHS I'm
sure people won't be surprised to see
this headline the NHS is broken I think
lots of people are aware of what's going
on because when they try and use Health
Services you know they face huge delays
um I think actually when it comes down
to it when we take a step back one of
the big issues is we don't spend enough
on Healthcare in this country so we do
spend less than um particular countries
in Europe for example countries like
Austria like Germany which are countries
that have more doctors paired than we do
more hospital beds per head
um you know there's different ways of
funding your health system but
ultimately we're not really spending
enough considering that we're an aging
Society
um the pace of medical technology
changing which means that as societies
get richer they tend to spend more of
their GDP on Healthcare and we just
haven't been keeping pace and that's
true if you look at the Rises that the
NHS historically had year one year that
hailed us from 2010 onwards due to
public spending cuts and it's true if
you look at International comparisons as
well so it's not just money but at the
moment we're not putting enough money
into health care we're spending too much
on acute services and not enough on
prevention not enough on Primary Care
not enough on the sort of healthcare
that stops people needing to go into
hospital for that Acute Care in in the
first place and then the problem is is
that once you get a system in which
there are delays and waiting lists are
you know at record eyes at the moment
partly as a result of the pandemic but
partly I think because of over a decade
of underfunding of the NHS relative
underfunding
um the issue is is that when you've got
people waiting longer for operations the
health conditions have to get worse
before they get treated by the NHS
that's worse for them in terms of their
long-term Health outcomes but it's also
worse in the long term as well because
once once your condition gets worse it
tends to be more expensive to treat so
so you know we've Really Got A system
that isn't working well at the moment
and for me onto funding if you look at
the international comparisons if you
look at the fact that we have far fewer
doctors nurses hospital beds per head
um you know that resourcing is very much
part of it and just quickly uh Mark it's
not the first time there's a kirstama or
indeed we're treating the Shadow on
health has talked about reform going
back to or making the case for
Neighborhood Health Services it feels a
bit like Cottage hospitals in some
respects to me which are you know some
of which have been wiped out
um just just very quickly is reform what
is required now
I think it will obviously need some form
of Reform I mean my colleagues at the
house magazine published an
investigation yesterday that found I
think 250 000 children have been uh
turned down effectively for mental
health care after being referred by
their GPS by NHS trusting there's a
whole Litany of these problems
the question is what kind of Reform is
Kirsten going to propose and will any of
the unions wear it you know neighborhood
healthcare system used to have GPS that
would go around people's houses do out
of hours calls that was effectively
scrapped in a contract negotiation I
don't hear the BMA rushing to reinstate
stuff like that okay mark thank you very
much for the Eds reform even if required
is exhausting for a a an overworked
Workforce certainly both of you thank
you both very much